كأس رايدر ،
أصبحت المباراة التي تقام كل سنتين بين أوروبا
والولايات المتحدة
عملاً تجاريًا كبيرًا مما كانت بطولة ودية إلى حد ما
تهيمن عليها الولايات المتحدة وتم لعبها في
الدورات التقليدية ،
فقد أصبحت لعبة رائعة من التنافس الشديد الذي
يتم لعبه غالبًا في مواقع جديدة
تتوق إلى الأضواء التي تستضيف
يمكن أن يجلب
الكأس الخلاصة إلى أن كوب ryder
هو ملكية ذات قيمة كبيرة
هذه الأيام لم يكن من المعتاد أن يكون كأسًا من الورق المقوى
يستخدم لخسارة الأموال في الوقت الحاضر ، إنه
مهرجان نقدي مطلق تقول الدراسات أن حوالي 100
مليون
هو رهان جيد للحصول على  المنطقة المراد الحصول عليها
من كأس ryder ، وهي ليست مبلغًا صغيرًا
من المال
لتنظيم كأس ryder ، يحتاج المكان الآن إلى
جيوب عميقة ، حيث يضمن منظمو حدث 2022 في روما
أكثر من 95 مليون يورو من
التمويل العام
الذي يخضع حاليًا للمساءلة من قبل
مجلس الشيوخ الإيطالي.
ما الذي ستحصل عليه روما في المقابل
كمثال يقدر أن التأثير
الاقتصادي للاقتصاد الاسكتلندي
كان أكثر من 100 مليون جنيه إسترليني بعد أن قدم
المنظمون  تم الإبلاغ عن 20 مليون جنيه إسترليني
لاستضافة الحدث في غلين إيجلز
في عام 2014. إنه استثمار مهم جدًا
بنفس القدر ، فنحن ننتج دراسات الأثر الاقتصادي
التي قمنا بها
ونعمل عليها لباريس والتي توضح
أن قيمة
الحدث هائلة.  تعرف أنها تعمل ،
وبالتالي في وضع جيد لتكون
قادرًا على إجراء هذه
المحادثات مع العلم أنك
تتحدث عن شيء يمثل احتمالًا جذابًا للغاية
إذا كان استثمارًا مكلفًا ولكن
أي شيء سيحقق هذا
النوع من النتيجة النهائية
ربما يحتاج إلى  تتناوب الأماكن المضيفة
بين أوروبا والولايات المتحدة
كل عامين
، وبينما تم اختيار أماكن الولايات المتحدة
حتى عام
2036 ، تم تحديد موقع 2022 فقط
في روما ، إيطاليا في أوروبا
، من المؤكد أن عددًا من الأماكن
ستقدم عطاءات لكأس 2026 ryder و  هذا هو المرشح الأول الحالي الذي
يجرؤ على العزبة في أيرلندا ، وهو منتجع من فئة الخمس نجوم
في مقاطعة ليمريك
يملكه رجل الأعمال الملياردير
جي بي مكمانوس.
أعيد تصميمه
مع وضع كأس ryder في الاعتبار ،
فهو يشتمل على ثقوب مصممة للمخاطر الدرامية
والمكافآت التي
تعرض المدرجات على بعد سبعة كيلومترات
من طرق الدعم
ناهيك عن 21 كيلومترًا من قنوات الكابلات
المثبتة بالفعل تحت الأرض
لبث مثل هذا الحدث الواسع النطاق ،
ونحن نعلم بالتأكيد أن jp سيكون
سفير رائع ومضيف رائع
لكوب ryder وما قام ببنائه بطريقة جريئة
ليس أقل من مثير للإعجاب فهو يتمتع
باهتمام دقيق بالتفاصيل
والتزام بالتميز الذي
نتوقعه من أي شيء تشاركه JP
في قوله  أنه من الواضح أننا
نتحمل مسؤولية النظر في جميع
الخيارات
لتقديمها إلى مجلس إدارتنا
لأعضائنا لأصحاب المصلحة لدينا ثم اتخاذ
القرار الأفضل
للجولة الأوروبية وبصراحة تامة
نمو اللعبة عالميًا
والعلامة التجارية لكأس رايدر  في حد ذاته ،
أيًا كان الموقع الذي
سيُنظم فيه تكاليف كأس ريدر 2026
ستكون كبيرة ولكن الأرباح قد تكون
أكبر
منك